things used to be simple verbal gaming
PCs and there were gaming consoles if
you wanted to play on your living room
TV and didn't want to deal with things
like driver updates then you get a
console alternatively if you got a kick
out of things like terminal commands and
like the accuracy of a mouse and
keyboard then you get a PC these days
things aren't so simple with the release
of steam OS and the upcoming onslaught
of steam machines valve is hoping to
kick the console out of the living room
and replace it with a small gaming PC
that's easy on the eyes and lets you
play all your favorite PC games from the
comfort of your couch but with 13cm
machines hitting the market from a
variety of manufacturers it can be
difficult to choose between the lot
whether you're after a machine that's
portable enough to carry around to a
mate's place the most powerful one on
the market or just something that won't
break the bank I can help you choose a
steam machine that's right for you if
you've already got a monster PC gaming
setup or you just poured an awful lot of
money into upgrades you probably won't
want to spend another grant or two on a
steam machine luckily there are some
options that aren't gonna cost you a
bunch with most PC games offering
comprehensive controller support and the
new steam controller aiming to be a
keyboard and mouse replacement playing
PC games from the comfort of your couch
is totally doable lower-end steam boxes
from cyber PowerPC and iBUYPOWER start
at 499 bucks and with good AMD
processors and discreet graphics cards
on board they'll happily power through
all but the most demanding of PC games
at fair settings but if you've already
got a mighty PC in the household why not
tap into its power and strain games
directly to your steam machine by using
your existing monster PC and steams
in-home streaming technology streaming
games to a small form-factor steam
machine over a local network is an
attractive option given that you can
play PC games in your living room
without sacrificing visual fidelity and
without having a huge PC Tao
at CEO TV themes in-home streaming
technology is still in beta but if you
have a spare laptop lying around you can
try it out for yourself right now
maybe you're keen on the idea of playing
PC games but you don't have a computer
that can handle the latest releases or
maybe you don't really want to build
your own PC but you're interested in
hopping on that whole master race
bandwagon there are a few beefy options
if you want to go all-out although they
aren't going to be terribly kind to your
wallet
the first is digital storms vault 2
while it's a bit larger than some of the
other options and costs a hefty two and
a half grand it comes with a powerful
intel core i7 processor a gtx 780 Ti
graphics card sixteen gigabytes of RAM
and is fully liquid-cooled plus a dual
boot steam OS and Windows so you don't
have to rely on steam OS is currently
sparse library to get your game on
alternatively this web Halen box is a
tad cheaper at around $1500 and has
pretty similar hardware specs but it's
much closer to a traditional PC in shape
and size and the other options
these options are clearly expensive but
if money's no object and you want to
crank the likes of Crysis 3 to maximum
settings check out Falcon Northwest
Tinky box which costs just shy of $4,000
featuring space for up to four SSDs and
i7 processor and invidious outrageous
GTX Titan GPU this impressively small
box has all of the power you'll need to
run even some of the most demanding of
PC games it also comes in this sweet
black and blue color scheme which will
probably be the colour of your bank
account if you decide to go for it all
of these boxes are well-equipped to play
the latest PC games smoothly at the
highest of graphical settings and yes
they will outperform the Xbox one and
ps4 on multi-platform titles
the last option is predictably at the
middle ground for around a thousand
bucks there are a variety of steam
machines to choose from but you'll need
to do some comparisons of their various
tech specs and form factors to decide
what will best suit your needs do you
want a portable gaming machine you can
easily take over to a friend's house do
you want to play the latest releases at
high settings how much do you really
care about high-end graphics or do you
just want a thing to play Minecraft on
if it's like portable machine that can
hold its own is your priority then scans
NC 10 is a great albeit somewhat pricey
choice at around 1,200 bucks
featuring a core i3 processor and gtx
765 m in its base configuration it might
not have the hardware chops to run games
at their highest settings but for the
likes of dota 2 Starcraft 2 and
titanfall you'll be totally sets plus
the NC 10 looks to be one of the
thinnest team machines coming to the
market if you're willing to sacrifice
sleekness for value check out material
dot Nets box with an Intel Core i5 gtx
760 and eight gigabytes of ram it's
better value than the NC 10 at just over
$1000 even if it does have that
relatively dull and generic black box
look about it there are plenty of
options out there at the $1000 price
point whether you're hoping to
supplement your existing consoles and
gaming PC or replace them altogether be
sure to let me know in that commenting
section whether a specific steam machine
has caught your eye what aspects of
gaming Hardware are important to you and
whether you will or won't be buying a
steam machine on the last episode of the
gist I told you guys about how awesome
child of light was and mostly you said
yep child of light looks rad Chinna
triple7 wanted it pointed out that it's
granny earth combat system I strongly
recommend ground ear 1 & 2 in the
meantime to anybody who hasn't played
those wall 19 James 89 added I really
want this game but I'm just not prepared
to tolerate you playing
I think MSD failed pretty much wrapped
up the short and long of many of your
comments there by saying one thing I
know for sure about child of light is
that it's absolutely gorgeous that is it
for me today as always drop me your
thoughts and feelings in that commenting
box down below
and I'll see you again next week